Darwin's idea takes us all the way from
physics and chemistry the world of
lifeless meaningless purposeless matter
all the way to the most exalted purposes
and meanings from from poetry and ethics
to carbon atoms
all in one picture and that unifies the
the world and the world of inquiry I
think unlike any other idea before
Darwin it was not only hard I think was
impossible to imagine how this gap
between the living and the non-living
was really filled in and now we have a
pretty good understanding of not only
what the materials and the structures
are but how it got that way and that's
what's really impressive
well I think Darwin would realize that
human beings have evolved hardly at all
genetically since he published his book
what has evolved of course is our
understanding of the process and that's
evolved by cultural evolution and by
just the tremendous developments of
science which I'm sure he would be
thrilled beyond thrilled to see how much
of this process is now understood after
all he didn't have the concept of the
gene
he was quite frankly baffled by how
evolution could not get swamped by
so-called blending inheritance or
everything sort of mixes together to
produce mush now we have a very clear
understanding of that and he would have
been thrilled by that but even even more
than a half a century after he published
the Origin of Species William Bateson
the great geneticist early
twentieth-century geneticist couldn't
imagine and said it was inconceivable
that what he called nuclear chromatin
could be the material basis for heredity
well that's Deanna 8 and he just
couldn't imagine how it could because to
him that seemed homogeneous under all
known test it seemed to be just too
simple well now of course we know that
that nuclear chromatin has in the case
of human beings a double helix molecule
with three billion base pairs in it and
it's copied into every single cell in
our body that's stunning he couldn't
imagine that
well there's simplistic ways of doing it
and there's less simplistic ways and
let's push ahead firmly and avoid the
huge oversimplifications and settle for
the useful oversimplifications of course
it's complicated life is complicated if
if biologists had been dissuaded by
natural natural ists people you know if
those people who'd been studying the
orchid and the beaver and the honeybee
and the elm tree in the end the perch
had said Oh mr. Darwin my species is
much much much too complicated ever to
be explained by your theory first of all
they would be wrong and yes life is
complicated culture is complicated minds
are complicated but they're not so
complicated that we can't do good
analyses of what makes them calm